plantation owners started these fires
they want to create new areas for their
palm trees the fires are illegal but
they burn again and again the government
is trying to protect the rainforest and
biodiversity and the people who suffer
from the effects of the smoke the fruit
of the palm tree weighs up to four
kilograms the biggest consumers of the
oil from the fruit are Indonesia and
China followed by the European Union
it's cheaply used to cook with but is
also often an ingredient in food or
cosmetics palm oil is also used as a
biofuel additive in the EU however that
could end soon in an effort to protect
the rainforests the government in Kuala
lumper is coming out in support of the
650,000 small farmers whose livelihoods
depend on palm oil it says half the
forests are now protected the focus has
switched to increased productivity the
government has even introduced a
certificate for green plantations
Malaysia's threatened to retaliate at
the EU restricts imports there were
reports of an aviation show in langkawi
that the planned purchase of european
jet fighters could be stopped
instead chinese or other aircraft would
be an option we were one of the first
Asian countries to buy Russian planes
the government has also threatened to
boycott the planned free-trade agreement
between the European Union and the
Association of Southeast Asian Nations
well let's bring in Ashutosh Pompey from
our Southeast Asia desk
Ashutosh give us an idea of the scale of
this who's got more to lose Malaysia or
the UN is the EU playing fair
well Gerhard to be honest the Malaysian
market does not enjoy a lot of leverage
over the European Union the two did 40
billion worth of trade in 2017 in goods
and it's Malaysia is the 21st largest
trading partner for European Union
having said that Malaysia does have a
leverage when it comes to free trade
deals Malaysia could play a spoilsport
when when it comes to the a trade
ambitions of European Union in the
region the trade talks with Malaysia
have been on hold since 2012 and looking
at the currents in the arrow it seems
unlikely they are going to start anytime
soon now what that does is that that
effectively throws any possible free
trade deal with ASEAN which is European
Union's third largest trading partner
outside of Europe out of the picture
because European sees trade deals with
individual countries as building blocks
for a wider trade deal with ASEAN as a
whole Ashe knows how serious is
Malaysia's threat to cancel that
Eurofighter order well to me it seems
more like pressure tactic because Prime
Minister Mahathir did go and go ahead
and actually downplay the threat saying
it was only a suggestion now having said
that if I mean we wouldn't be surprised
if China actually walks away with a
fighter jet deal from Malaysia because
Malaysia has made some strange choices
when it comes to buying fighter jets in
the past weather when it was to do with
Sukhoi from Russia and also that would
be a big blow for the European jet
makers Eurofighter and the saw aviation
which have been actually campaigning
hard for almost a decade to win this
deal which could be valued at
and to billion dollars so blow blow for
the Eurofighter consortium but how
damaging is this for Malaysia's economy
briefly if you can Malaysia
depends a lot on palm oil exports I mean
but having but only to put things into
perspective overall and effect on the
GDP is not going to be huge because only
fifty twelve percent of the GDP is five
percent of total exports is palm oil
ostrich pond I thank you very much